I have some disturbing news for you out
of South Dakota take a look at this
headline alternative media syndicate
calm is reporting that police are
burning TPS misspelled in their headline
as TI p is belonging to people
protesting the Dakota access pipeline
with a horrifying photographic depiction
of the police brutality at the site of
the demonstration but take a closer look
at just the photo which I'm showing you
here why are the police dressed in civil
war uniforms and why are they riding
horses well it's actually because we'll
go back to the headline alternative
media syndicate calm is a fake news site
and this is fake news police did not
burn TPS at a Dakota access protest the
picture included in this article is
actually from an HBO film and the
generic looking sort of click baby links
on the side if you're looking at the
headline with us could maybe be part of
the giveaway that this is a fake news
site but regardless of that the article
that I showed you from alternative media
syndicate com has been shared on
Facebook nearly 300,000 times I've
actually seen people on Facebook friends
of mine post stuff from this website
it's one of the more popular fake or
sensationalist quote news websites and I
think this is a good opportunity to talk
about the change that is going on in
terms of trends and fake news fake news
during the 2016 election campaign was
rampant especially fake news that was
Pro Trump and it's completely plausible
that fake news helped Donald Trump win
the election we know that fake news
articles were some of the most shared
articles across social media during the
lead up to the November a the next
election and fake news is still alive
and well because it is so profitable
advertisers are paying a lot of money to
fake news websites and for the most part
the advertisers and even the publishers
don't have political motivations there
generate
in content based on what they think will
bring in the most traffic a lot of these
fake news sites originated in some of
the poorer Eastern European countries
the home of a lot of internet scams as
well and fake news is prosperous in part
because we have such a media literacy
problem in the United States where
people often don't have the know-how or
either even inclination to figure out
whether the news they're getting is real
however under Donald Trump since the
inauguration of Donald Trump the
left-leaning fake news sites are rising
far more quickly than the right-wing
fake news sites including the one I just
showed you stanford research has shown
that before the election it was the pro
Trump fake news that was dominating and
now it's the anti-trump fake news that
is dominating and factcheck.org director
Eugene Keely said whoever is in power is
going to be the target of fake news
before the election we had a Democratic
president we had Hillary Clinton the
Democratic candidate widely presumed to
be the favorite and eventual winner
Democrats were quote in power now Donald
Trump is in power and I think there is a
correlation between people who are
gullible or non media literate people
and people who are blindly contrarian
and conspiracy theorists and the fake
news publishers clearly understand this
let's take a look at some of the most
popular fake news sites on Facebook
we've got learn progress dot org we've
got abcnews.com dot co which is not the
same thing as ABC news we've got
politico.com naturalnews.com that's a
favorite we've got Global Research dot
CA humans are freecom the New York
evening calm and you know we'll just all
so go ahead with infowars.com certainly
not a left-leaning fake news site but a
right-leaning fake news site so I think
it's really
important Pat I've been talking about
the importance of media literacy for a
very long time and it really had nothing
to do with the specific trends of fake
news particularly now that we're seeing
fake news grow on the left quite a bit
and now that fake news is being used as
a catch-all basically to just criticize
positions that one doesn't like I don't
know that it's ever been more important
at least during the existence of the
david pakman show for people to really
understand how to fact-check and we've
talked a little bit about sources that
we don't use or sources that are on a
list of be skeptical about where we
would not do a story if the only source
reporting a story is on a particular
list we've talked about that and I think
it's really important for individual
news consumers to develop some similar
system for themselves yeah I mean we
have to call out fake news whenever we
see it whether it's coming from the left
or the right and I mean there's so many
crazy things going on within the Trump
administration that there's really no
point in resorting to fake news I mean
we have his campaign being investigated
for wrongdoing in collusion with Russia
we have his spokespeople like Sean
Spicer and Stephen Miller just making
these outright lies and misleading the
public so why is there even a point for
liberal websites to resort to fake news
I mean the real stuff is damning enough
I completely agree with you there's
enough real stories that are critical of
the right and expose why when it comes
to the Trump White House the emperor has
no clothes we've talked about so many of
them there's really no need to go in
this direction I completely agree with
you and we are thinking about doing some
kind of broader peace related to actual
fake news and I'll keep you posted on
that if it develops